some Democrats say if President Trump
did ask James Comey to end the FBI's
investigation of general plan that is
obstruction of justice Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill Capital Hill rather
where lawmakers from both parties now
want mr. Comey to testify Nancy good
morning good morning this development
does seem to be a turning point for some
Republicans whose instinct up until now
has been to stand by the president or
minimize his mistakes the difference in
this situation is that frankly many of
those Republicans are more apt to
believe Jim Comey's word than they are
to believe the president's this is not
good for America speaking with Bob
Schieffer at a dinner last night Arizona
Senator John McCain made the Nixon
comparison for the first time I think
it's reaching the point where it's of
Watergate size and scale as he spoke his
fellow Republican jason Chaffetz who
chairs the House Committee on government
oversight was firing off a letter to the
FBI giving the agency a week to turn
over all memoranda notes summaries and
recordings referring or relating to any
communications between Comey and the
president South Carolina's Lindsey
Graham said Comey himself should come to
the hill I want to hear from him GOP
leaders have long resisted democratic
calls for an independent congressional
Commission to examine the Russian
connection but Florida Republican Carlos
Crivello said that needs to change
increasingly Republicans believe that we
have to do something different than what
we're doing today
Idaho's Jim Risch was one of the few
Republicans willing to defend the
president I think it's getting better as
time goes on you know what $40 doing
this is about two days as Democrats
argued the Cundy encounter is the
clearest sign yet
obstruction of justice there is I think
mounting concern over just how this
administration appears to be interfering
with the Russia investigation a
spokeswoman for House Speaker Paul Ryan
says that he wants all the facts and
that he thinks it is appropriate for the
House Oversight Committee to do what it
needs to do to get its hands on this
James Comey memo Norah all right we'll
be watching Nancy thank you so much